so on the surface Choi's a kind of
millennial that think pieces are made of
he's arrogant self-centered and
convinced that he is smarter than people
give him credit for his favorite topics
of conversation are girls sneakers and
cars right not a surprise for someone
who was a teenager just a few years ago
but Joy's mannerisms they reveal the
patterns of someone who is scared
troubled and ensure the future now joy
also embodies a many positive qualities
his generation is known for an
entrepreneurial spirit an independent
streak and a dedication to his parents
he believes in hard work and has tried
gigs and both the illicit and
underground economies but he hasn't had
any luck and is just trying to find his
way and still dances between both worlds
when I met Troy a few years ago he had
been employed as a golf caddie at a
local Country Club carrying bags for
rich men and women who often never even
acknowledged his existence before that
he sold sneakers on Facebook he even
tried selling candy bars and water
bottles but he wasn't making enough
money to help his parents out or save up
for a car anytime soon so Troy saw how
hard his immigrant mother from Jamaica
work and how little she got back in
return and he vowed Troy vowed to take a
different path so he ended up selling
drugs and then he got caught and right
now he's trying to figure out his next
steps in a country where money equals
power quick money at least for a while
gives young men and women like him a
sense of control over their lives though
he said he mainly did it because he
wanted stability I wanted a good life he
told me I got greedy and I got caught
yet the amazing thing about Troy is it
he still believes in the American dream
he still believes that with hard work
despite being arrested that he can move
on up now
I don't know if choice dreams came true
he disappeared from the program for
trouble youth that he was involved in
and slipped through the cracks
but on that day that we spoke I could
tell that more than anything more than
anything joy was happy that someone
listened to his dreams and asked him
about his future so I think about Troy
and his optimism when I think in the
reality that so many young black
Millennials face when it comes to
realizing their dreams I think about all
the challenges that so many black
Millennials have to endure in a world
that tells them they can be anything
they want to be if they work hard but
actually doesn't sit down to listen to
their streams or hear stories about
their struggle and we really we really
need to listen to this generation if we
hope to have a healthy and civil society
going forward because Millennials of
color they make a fit mate they make up
a fair chunk of the US and the world
population now when we talk about
Millennials a group that is often
labeled as entitled lazy over educated
non-committal and narcissistic the
conversations often swirl around avocado
toast overpriced lattes in fancy jaunt
abroad you probably have heard all these
things before but Millennials are not a
monolith actress Lena Dunham maybe the
media's representation of this
generation but Troy and other voices
like his are also part of the story
in fact Millennials are the largest and
most diverse adult population in this
country 44% of all American Millennials
are non-white but often you wouldn't
even know it at all no sure there are
similarities within this population born
between 1981 and 1996 perhaps many of us
do love avocado toast and lattes I know
I do
right but there are also extreme
differences often between Millennials of
color and white Millennials in fact all
too often it seems as though we're
virtually living in different worlds
now black Millennials a group of a group
that I have researched for a book I
recently wrote are the perfect example
of the blind spot that we have when it
comes to this group for example we have
lower
rates of homeownership we have higher
student debt we get ID'd more at voter
registration booths we are incarcerated
at higher rates we make less money we
have higher numbers of employment even
when we do go to college I should say
and we get married at lower rates and
honestly that's really just the
beginning
now none of these struggles are
particularly new right young black
people in America had been fighting
really fighting hard to get their
stories told for centuries after the
Civil War and the 1800s reconstruction
failed to deliver the Equality that the
end of slavery should have heralded so
young people moved to the north and the
West to escape discriminatory Jim Crow
policies then as segregation raged in
much of the country young black people
helped spearhead civil rights campaigns
in the 1950s and 1960s after that some
people embraced black power and then
became Black Panthers and then the next
generation they turned to hip-hop to
make sure their voices were heard and
then Barack Obama hopeful that he too
may bring about change and when that
failed when we realized we were still
brutalized and battered we had to let
the world know that our lives still
mattered now as now when technology
allows more video of our pain and
struggle to be broadcast to the world we
wonder like what is next our country
feels more polarized than ever yet we
are still being told to pull up our
pants be respectable be less angry smile
more and work harder right even the
mullen even the attitudes of Millennials
themselves are overdue for an update
research done by the Washington Post in
2015 about this supposedly woke group
found that 31% of white Millennials
think that that blacks are lazy er than
white and 23% say they're not as
intelligent like these are like
surprising things to me and shocking and
these responses are not that much
different than generations in the past
and it shows that unfortunately this
generation is repeating the same old
stereotype types and tropes of the past
now study conducted by David
binder research in MTV in 2014 I found
that 84% of young Millennials were
taught by their families that everyone
should be equal this is a really great
thing a really positive stuff but only
37% in that group actually talked about
race with their families so I can
understand why things may be confusing
to some there are definitely black
Millennials who are succeeding Marvel's
Black Panther directed by black
millennial Ryan Coogler and showcasing
many others Brooke all sorts of Records
there's a crop of television shows by
creatives like donald glover lena ways
and easter ray beyonce like is the queen
right she is like everything young black
authors are winning awards Serena
Williams is still dominating on the
tennis courts despite all her haters and
there's a crop of new politicians and
activists running for office so I don't
want to like kill these moments of black
joy that I to revel in but I want to
make it clear that these winds are too
few and far between for people that's
been here for over 400 years like that's
insane right and most people still don't
really understand the full picture right
our stories are still misunderstood our
bodies are still taken advantage of and
our voices our voices are silenced in a
world that still shows little concern
for our everyday struggles so our
stories need to be told in a multitude
of ways by a range of voices talking
about diverse and nuanced topics and
they really need to be listened to and
it's not just here in America right it's
all around the world
Millennials make up 27% of the world's
population that's around 2 billion
people and with countries like India
China Indonesia and Brazil along with
the United States accounting for 50% of
the world's Millennials it's clear that
the white often male heterosexual
narrative of the Millennial is only
telling half the story now there's many
people trying to broaden the palette
they're fighting to get their stories
told and busts a millennial stereotype
whether its students in South Africa
protesting statues of Cecil Rhodes
Michaela Cole making us laugh from the
UK or hasa who is framing views about
Nigeria in my
online right but I want to make it clear
I've want to make it really clear to
everyone that just because things look
more equal than they did in the 20th
century doesn't mean that things are
equitable at all it doesn't mean our
experiences are equable and it certainly
doesn't mean that a post-racial society
that thing that we talked about so much
ever became close to being a reality I
think of Joe while a middle-class
20-something who did everything the
right way but she couldn't go to her
dream school because it was simply too
expensive or jalisa
who knows she can't be mediocre at her
job the same where her white the same
way that her white peers can or Trina
who knows that people judge her
unconventional family choices in a
different way than if she were a white
woman or after a B who knows that the
roles he takes and gets in Hollywood are
different because of his skin color and
then there's Simon right so Simon by all
means would be an example of someone
who's made it he's a CFO at a tech
company in San Francisco he has a degree
from MIT and he's worked at some of the
hottest tech companies in the world but
when I asked Simon when I asked Simon if
he had achieved the American dream it
took him a while to respond while
acknowledging that he had a really
comfortable life he admitted that under
different circumstances he might have
chosen a different path Simon really
loves photography but that was never a
real option for him my parents weren't
able to subsidize me through that sort
of thing Simon said maybe that's
something my children could do so it's
these kind of stories the quieter more
subtle ones to reveal the often unique
and untold stories of black Millennials
that show how even dreaming may differ
between communities so we really need to
listen and hear the stories of this
generation now more than ever is the
baby boomers age and Millennials come to
prominence we can talk all we want to
about pickling business pickling
businesses and Bush in Brooklyn or
avocado toast but leaving out the
stories and the voices of black
millennial large swath
as a population it will only increase
divisions so stories of black
Millennials brown Millennials and all
Millennials of color really need to be
told and they also need to be listened
to
we'd be a far better off country and
world thank you
[Applause]